je crois qu il est il est très
perceptible que les élus ont souhaité un
rééquilibrage des pouvoirs un
rééquilibrage des pouvoirs pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord peut-être pour
faire entendre mieux et davantage la
voix des territoires savait que le
président et gouvernement ont donné le
sentiment peut-être d'être plus
intéressé par les métropoles les grandes
villes que par l'ensemble les fractures
territoriales et ça c'est un message qui
a été envoyé très fortement
est ce que vous estimez que ce soir fait
une défaite pour la république en marché
pour emmanuel macron en tout cas c'est
un succès pour la droite
ça c'est c'est incontestable un succès
aussi pour gérard larcher et parce que
je crois que par sa personnalité par son
énergie il a su fédérer et jésus
réassurer pas que les yvelines pardon
mais gérard larcher a une aura qui
dépasse beau de beaucoup les yvelines et
moi je les ai vus faire cette campagne
de manière très déterminé très
méthodique et plaidé pour chaque
territoire de france et je crois que
c'est ça que les élus rendent mais je me
permets de relance n'avait pas vraiment
répondu à la question est-ce une défaite
pour la république en marche et pour le
président de la république
en tout cas c'est une très claire
volonté de rééquilibrer les pouvoirs et
ça ça veut dire que il ya le sentiment
peut-être d'une hyper concentration des
pouvoirs aujourd'hui une assemblée
pléthorique et j'allais dire un peu aux
ordres peut-être une absence de
contre-pouvoir il faut des
contre-pouvoirs dans la démocratie les
français n'aiment pas donner les pleins
pouvoirs à quelqu'un et j'ajoute comme
monsieur mélenchon veut exercer sans
contre-pouvoir dans la rue ben moi je
suis très satisfaite aujourd'hui il ya
un contre-pouvoir démocratique qui soit
au sénat et qui soient respectueux des
institutions de la république
est ce que vous redoutez peut-être la
création d'un groupe les constructif ici
au sénat et une implosion du groupe et
l'air non je ne redoute rien et je
j'espère en tout cas j'appelle mes amis
qui seraient tentés de
de quitter le groupe et l'air à
réfléchir parce que je crois moi
personnellement pour peut être unis et
divers c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que j'ai
créé un mouvement libre au sein des
élèves c'est à dire qu'en réalité on
peut exprimer au sein de l air et au
sein du groupe elle est au sénat une
sensibilité peut-être un peu différent
est liée à la place chez les
républicains pour pouvoir s'exprimer
aujourd'hui c'est ce que je souhaite est
en tout cas ça a été le sens hélas hélas
et la nécessité de la création de libre
qui fait qu'on est divers et on a des
sensibilités différentes mais on reste
ensemble
gérard larcher a estimé qu'il y aurait
une opposition exigeante ici qui va
émaner du scénar est ce que on peut être
constructif et exigeant à la fois
salengro moi je plaide pour une
opposition juste les 2 - sens opposition
parce que les constructif pour moi sont
des ralliés au gouvernement ils ne sont
pas dans l'opposition puisqu'il vote la
confiance ils votent les budgets donc
non ils sont pas dans l'opposition une
opposition mais juste c'est-à-dire
qu'ils votent
quand c'est bien et qu'ils ne s'opposent
pas et sur la réforme constitutionnelle
on sait bien que le président de la
république aura besoin du sénat et on a
besoin de convaincre les sénateurs